I mean who doesn't love a good ghost
story continuing with my overdue reviews
for Doctor Who modern era that I don't
have videos up for let's get to episode
three of series one the unquiet dead our
first historically set episode and this
was one that I was definitely overdue to
give a revisit to cuz they have probably
only seen it twice I don't remember the
last time see it this is one that I tend
to skip unreal watches I don't hate it
I've never hated it but I remember
always finding it a bit dull I find most
of the historical set ones especially
ones that feature a famous historical
figure to be a bit dull and I am glad it
rewashing cuz it's me I almost said it's
better than I remember it I'm not sure
it's better than I remember
there are more good things in it then I
remember the problems I have with it I
still have so well let's start positive
the doctor
Eccleston he's still doing great roses
is interesting in this eye I don't love
the interaction she has with Gweneth you
know the the whole sort of you know
trying to get this girl to be you know
to try and make more of her life I mean
that's I get it I get her instinct to do
that but at the same time one liked it
you're imposing sensibilities that don't
belong here and I guess I I I could go
for that more if the episode like kind
of addresses it a bit more but it
doesn't I mean we haven't one to kind of
go on like no you're being weird and
it's kind of just left at that um but I
mean are roses performance chemistry
with Capaldi still them some Capaldi God
Eccleston
is still spot on so that works great the
whole thing with Charles Dickens I'm
really of two minds of because on the
one hand I actually think the character
is really well performed and you know
the actor does about as good as could
have been done with the part he plays it
really well and he does what is being
called on for the character in terms of
the characters arc and everything else
does a really good job but I still don't
really love it I think a big part of my
inherent issue with the historical set
episodes that a feature a famous figure
from history is it it always comes
across like the children's educational
television version you know they spout
references to the things we will all
recognize and you know it's that they're
all they're almost always the most
obvious form that could be and they're I
mean there are a few exceptions here and
there sometimes they actually play with
that they did in robots of Sherwood and
I like that but most of them they just
take these characters and they're just
they're so I know it sounds weird to say
they're too historically accurate but
that's not quite what I mean they're -
they're to what I would expect based off
my knowledge of these characters which
makes them less of characters and more
of I don't know just famous historical
figure porn that's an awkward sentence
but I don't know if I'm making any sense
at all but it's a big part of inherently
why I don't like most of the historical
figures who turn up in these things
so that is working against him but again
the actor performs it very well what it
is that he's doing the other characters
are all good they're solid they're fun
there's some of the humor that is kind
of lost on me simply because I'm a man
I can like the jokes of I'm gonna die in
cod if like that has no meaning to me I
don't really know what the US equivalent
to Cardiff is I don't know if it's like
he's saying I'm gonna die in Newark
you know I assume it's something like
that but because I have to think about
it and make that connection the joke
misses its window to work so but that's
not a fault with a joke or even the show
that's just I'm American I I can only do
so much to put my mindset into that of a
UK viewer because I'm not so the whole
thing with the ghosts and the guilt it's
played off a lot better than my memory
of it was because my memory was that it
was very cheesy and the effects are a
little cheesy but I need you
Ferhat for when this air the effects
were more than respectable so I need to
kind of go easy on that but the whole
thing with the this gaseous form that it
basically tricks the doctor into helping
them what I like about it I pretty much
everything I'll you about this comes
down to Eccleston because when they
invoke the name of the time war you can
see the impact that has on him and it
makes his choices make a lot more sense
because he feels a certain degree of
responsibility for what has happened to
this race and so that's kind of getting
him to overlook some of things that
should be warning signs he's kind of
bypassing them and it makes sense given
everything that's going on so that works
actually quite well and Eccleston has a
number of really good moments and some
of the moments that make him seem a
little bit more alien which I always
appreciate with any doctor so like him
saying you know well yeah they can use
dead people's bodies Andros very taken
aback like no they can't and the doctor
going yeah they can nobody else is using
them it's recycling these people are
dying yeah they can so yeah and it makes
total sense because he wouldn't have the
sentimentality around
a dead body that human would and he
doesn't and he's going pragmatic on the
thing and and all that works works
really quite well eventually as the
whole thing plays out you know it it's
okay there's a moment that like even
first time watching it I was like wait
what which is when they think they're
gonna die and the doctor holds Rose's
hand he goes I'm glad I met you Rose
Tyler I think it's just too soon to pull
that III think that line would worked
fine yeah well you know what episode six
halfway through the sees through the
series roughly that line would have been
perfect three three episodes in only
second trip he's taken with her I'm
really glad I met you like in that aw
what like I mean I know he's about to
die and all that but it just I don't I
don't like it they're over selling the
speed and strength of this connection
and it makes me push against it cuz I'm
going really so that moment bugged me at
the time still kind of does a little bit
um there are a lot of little random
things here and they're both good and
bad there's this line from Dickens where
he you know he gets into the funeral
parlors like what the Shakespeare is
going on here and I I don't know if I
had forgotten that joke or if I didn't
get it when I heard it before but uh he
says that because you know what do we
say what the Dickens is going on but he
is Dickens so he says what the
Shakespeare it's kind of cute and here's
something that I found myself thinking
about what was the Undertaker gonna do
with rose because he knocked her out
said she'd seen too much and what
exactly was he gonna do because I
actually think that he and gwennyth have
killed people before that's actually
kind of implied at the front end after
the the old woman's body comes back to
life and strangles I think it's her
grandson and in the scene after iguana
vas Snead you know the Undertaker you
know did you take care of whatever the
guys name was and he's like no she took
care of him and he's like wait a minute
if you're using took care of as a
metaphor for killed and she did she says
you have you killed him like I could
understand that I could have other
meaning but then I come back to rose
again I'm like but but you knocked
around sucker in the back of the what
were you gonna do so I I don't know if
the show is implying something that I
just never picked up on before or if
it's just if or if it's by accident
because it certainly doesn't it does the
the tone in the mood and the way which
these characters are presented in the
rest of the episode doesn't seem to
stand up with there are a couple of
murderers yeah other things seem to
suggest that yeah I don't know who to
blame for that
I want to blame the writer this was
Gaius wasn't it I think it was seems
like him that's not enough that's a
little mean but I mean overall this is
this is a very middle-of-the-road
episode for me there are things that are
good in it there are good moments most
of them belong to Eccleston the
supporting cast is solid although you
know I my own personal taste in terms of
the historical failures so yeah
that is what it is and but you know it
was there was more positives to it than
I've recalled so I mean that's that's
something and it does go to show that it
is important for me to rewatch these as
I am doing these reviews and not just go
off memory because it's been a while for
some of these so I think I'm gonna wrap
it up there it's decent
it's not like it's I mean there's not
like the show suddenly took a nosedive
but it it is a step down from the
episode before and it's just it's fine
it's a fine episode and I and I get way
I usually skip it but the unquiet dead
what are your thoughts on it whatever
they are drops on the government in the
comments and let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff to do there's
like likes and subscribe buttons for
those and there's a link to the patreon
and there's other stuff down there too
if you want to check it out by all means
go nuts and remember folks you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]